Yes, honey!
Life don't get any better than this.
Twelve strangers
are about to compete
for a life-changing cash prize.
I've never seen anything like this.
We're not in Oklahoma anymore.
They think
they'll be living a life of luxury…
This is literally paradise.
…but there's one catch.
Oh, wait.
Oh, crap. What is going on?
I'm sorry, what?
In this game,
everyone starts with nothing.
Is that the bathroom?
This is so awful.
Did I sign up for Fyre Festival?
I don't believe I did.
Alliances will get you
into paradise…
-I'm here with y'all, seriously.
-Absolutely.
-No backstabbers?
-No backstabbers.
I wanna be in that villa.
I wanna be on top.
…but enemies
can send you back to hell.
You got a target on you now.
-It's about to get really juicy.
-Really?
I need people to vote for me.
The only way
to get back into that villa.
Who are these two newbies?
Nobody's safe. The games begin.
We might even be pitted
against each other.
I would never have done that to you.
Something scandalous
is happening.
Whatever I have to do, I will do.
We need to have
a moment of silence
for our friends back at camp.
And eat. Let's go.
This is a brutal game.
I am telling you right now,
do not take this box.
No disrespect. I just don't like you.
You're not gonna sit here
and tell me my emotions
are an act.
Welcome to paradise.